dans les yvelines plusieurs maires ont
été réélus dès ce premier tour des
municipales 2020 à poissy karl olive
liste divers droite remporte l'élection
dans cette ville de 37 mille habitants
vainqueur en 2014 avec 62,42 % des voix
ils l'emportent encore plus largement ce
dimanche 15 mars
ce candidat à totalise 75 60 % des
suffrages
la hauteur de ce résultat oui je dois
avouer que c'est parce que nous nous
attendions même si on était convaincus
du travail qui était fait savez j'ai
répété pendant six ans que la réalité c
est celle du terrain en adéquation avec
les habitants moi je suis né ici j'ai
grandi ici j'aime les habitants comme
les habitants même je le crois à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la liste san siro
coeur 2020 mené par sonia broc maire de
la commune depuis février 2019 s'impose
avec 55 à 60% des suffrages face à la
liste menée par lydie du long pont à
saint germain en laye arnaud péricard en
place depuis 2010 est a lui aussi
remporté son premier succès en tant que
tête de liste
l'homme politique diverse en totalise 63
points 89 % des suffrages il devance
notamment kane richard de la liste saint
germain écologique et solidaire
ça prouve que les saint germain - se
retrouve dans le projet que nous leur
avons proposé dans la rigueur qui est la
nôtre dans le sérieux et dans les
projets que nous avons pour notre ville
pour les six prochaines années
je crois que nous sommes des gens
crédibles nous l'avons démontré pendant
six ans il nous allons leur démontrer
sur les six prochaines années
à sartrouville pierrefonds maire
historique de la commune depuis 1995 va
repartir pour un nouveau mandat sa liste
sartrouville j'aime ma vie l'emporté
assez facilement avec 62 27 % des
suffrages le maire sortant devance
isabelle à magglio terrisse à bois
d'arcy pas de souci pour la liste divers
droite philippe benassaya le maire
sortant en place depuis 2014 repartira
pour un nouveau mandat il devance e
jocelyne a nié avec 63 points 67 % à
vélizy-villacoublay pascal thévenot mer
depuis 2014 s'est lui aussi largement
imposée dès ce premier tour avec plus de
60% des suffrages
les trois autres candidats didier
blanchard hughes or seul un il ya six
mines à bellezane maths sont largement
distancés
c'est assez rare avait dit et puis y
avait quand même quatre listes
donc c'était pas images obligatoirement
faciles à l'imaginer avant on a tout
fait pour puisque aujourd'hui
finalement on est un peu les seuls à
avoir un programme est maintenant bas
c'est un peu la satisfaction des visions
sur ce qu'on a fait ces six dernières
années à versailles commune de 85 mille
habitants françois de mazières le maire
divers-droite sortant partira pour un
troisième mandat comme en 2014 elle a
été élue dès le premier tour cette fois
ci avec 63% des suffrages
quoique les versaillais était satisfait
du bilan
en tout cas ils nous l'ont montré dans
le vote et je l'en remercie du fond du
coeur parce que la vie de mère c'est une
vie totalement engagé et c'est une vie
où finalement on a un sentiment
quasiment d'affection à mantes la jolie
le maire sortant rafael cogner en place
depuis décembre 2017 a été réélu avec 72
2% des suffrages il devance marc jamais
une liste divers gauche
enfin conflans sainte honorine a list
conflent en avant menée par laurent bros
remporte le premier tour avec plus de
51%
l'homme politique partira pour un
deuxième mandat consécutif